salut à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode d'envergure c'est l'épisode 2 de
la saison 4 et pour poursuivre notre
discussion de l'épisode 1 on va poser
les bases par rapport à la draft 2021 la
semaine dernière on a fait on a présenté
les français qui seraient des candidats
sérieux on a également présenté les
freshman qu'ils se battraient pour le
faire ce pic
il est temps de présenter cette semaine
les français qui joue en nba cette fois
les internationaux qui jouent en europe
et puis les joueurs de nba qui sont pas
en première année donc les sophomores
juniors et seniors dont les âmes et les
américains les appelle les parcs la
semaine pour cela alan nico manu salut
les gars salut tout le monde
ça nous allait vous avez le menu nous on
est prêt pour démarrer en tout cas pour
manuel année nico dont c'est le premier
podcast dans la saison 4 d'envergure
épisode 2 c'est parti
[Musique]
alors messieurs je vais commencer avec
nico tiens puisque c'est peut-être toi
qui vas parler des prospects qui peuvent
être drafté le plus haut
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est même sûr
on a parlé la semaine dernière des
français évoluant en france
voilà qui pouvait se faire drafté en
et là je t'ai demandé de présenter je
vais te demander de nous présenter un
peu les les prospects internationaux
donc à l'instar de données f10 à l'année
dernière par exemple les joueurs
internationaux qui peuvent être drafté
alors je vais à nous dire le tri premier
tour je t'ai dit en gros tous les
candidats potentiels à un premier tour
quoi donc pour poser pour juste
expliquer le concept je donne un joueur
à nico mais évidemment il mais c'est sa
petite liste avant etc présentation
sommaire tous les joueurs dont on parle
ici et dont on a parlé dans le podcast
épisode 1 seront auront leur scouting
report lord podcast scouting report
personnel ou reviendra en longueur sur
leur jeu ce soir on fait des topos des
présentations brève que vous pouvez
reprendre allègrement lors de vos
discussions n 6 et slash draft nba à la
machine à café
nico ils auront même lorsque coating
report très rapidement sur le site
envergure c'est exactement envergure
point ses eaux pour tous les scouts in
gris portés aussi les articles de
présentation les des joueurs à suivre en
aide si de gaulle est cette saison alors
nico le bas tiens tu vas devoir choisir
ça va être bien père cas si nous nous
garons bas en premier pour moi ça sera
père cassine plus que garou bas donc qui
est ce croate alors qu'au père cassine
ces deux mètres 06 née en 2002 croate
qui joue au cibona zagreb
c'est un petit point stats
j'ai pris à chaque fois les stades de la
plus forte ligue dans laquelle ils
évoluent en attaque en adriatique league
je vais y arriver ces huit matchs 24
minutes 11 points 6 rebonds une passe
une interception 3 balles perdues il a
32 % à 3 points donc ceux qui le suivent
depuis les 8 16
nous on l'a connu en initiateur en une
sorte de big ward sur pionnier capable
de rouler sur les compétitions de jeunes
on l'avait ensuite aperçu plus lourd
plus costaud au à l'euroligue junior à
valence l'an dernier cette année
rocco et son caractère de cochon il
s'installe en intrigue en adriatique
league et dans la ligue croate comme une
sorte de poème forward sur le papier en
réalité c'est beaucoup plus fort ward
que paint quelque chose il a plus la
balle en main pour créer il pose des
écrans iggy pop pour le tir à trois
points il flaire pour le midi rôle pour
aller au cercle
il a un bagage technique d'un très haut
niveau
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on avait
l'impression quand il était jeune
moi je trouve que aujourd'hui le haendel
il est pas élite et comme le corps a
perdu en vitesse qui l'est moins délier
ça se voit un peu plus carte blanche au
cibona cette année comme il l'avait l'an
dernier à oum donc on peut compter sur
lui pour faire des stats et pour finir
sur sa présentation
c'est un peu le même profil que abidjan
en moins à rien moins créatif en plus
soliste plus avec une mentalité de tueur
ok donc j'avais juste demandé la semaine
dernière à antoine d'année et romain de
donner vraiment le ski vendeur
le gros point fort est ce que toi tu va
observer particulièrement en deux mots
donc pour lui ce qui est vendeur
c'est le ratio taille et ce qu'ils la
skil cette technique c'est c'est du haut
de gamme et le point fort
je dirais ses qualités de scoreur hockey
est ce que tu vas observé cette année en
termes de axes de progression
c'est ce que je disais dans la langue
présentation c'est pour moi il a
vraiment un profil à devenir un boris
diaw
blond et croate maintenant
ce qu'on a vu c'est dans la création
c'est faible donc je je l'attend là
dessus voir si capable de le faire à ce
niveau là ok parfait
rockhopper cassine haut contrairement à
la semaine dernière on va on va tourner
comme ça vous resterez pas trop
longtemps inactif messieurs ça permettra
de donner du rythme à ce podcast bon
manuel ânes connaissent évidemment reco
par cas sinon je connais tous chez
envergure on vous invite à aller voir
les matchs du cibona zagreb donc manu ce
soir à la lourde tâche de vous présenter
les français de n 6 et qui pourrait être
drafté en 2021 s'il se présente ou pour
certains sont automatiquement éligibles
par qui tu commences manu olivier sarr
olivier sarah kane d'ugo legrand poste
cinq cas étaient de kantigui qui a été
transféré cette année pour sa dernière
saison l'a fait trois 3 années à wake
forest 3e année dans un programme qui a
été un peu moyen qu'un virus son coach
ne s'est pas très bien passé sur la fin
donc il s'est dit tiens je vais aller
dans un programme plus dupes et dans une
conférence un peu plus huppé aussi donc
ça c'est un grand poste 5 à ses mobiles
tous faim seven footer assez assez bon
dans le dans le rebond et la protection
du cercle et cette année fin d'un
pinceau son parcours wake forest est là
qu est une fille on voit qu'il est
capable de shooter un peu développée à
terme est allé un peu plus loin à voir à
3 points notamment dans les corners la
ligne à un peu plus un peu plus proche
moi je dois intéressant si au niveau du
quelques moves poste bas où il a réussi
a dit à 2000 et ses adversaires par sa
puissance par son sens footwork donc ça
c'est ici intéressant problème ma tin
tuc il est pas trop trop servi ils n'ont
pas forcément trouvé le le meneur encore
adéquat pour pour l'aider donc c'est
après ce que moi ce que je vais attendre
sur eux chez lui c'est sa vraiment sa
progression du audiard
parce que je pense qu'à terme sur sur sa
saison s'il est bien suivi et bien
constant il peut il peut arriver à être
vraiment fiable
sur des tirs à mi distance ok donc un
grand qui pourrait tirer
j'ajoute puisque ce sera de façon
marquée dans l'article prévieux des
seniors puis parlait de sa mobilité
c'est vrai qu'ils bougent un petit peu
mieux au périmètre la miss art par
rapport aux années j'ai beaucoup sur
lesquels comme il a eus quoi deux trois
matches de kenshi je crois c'est de
saison et j'ai vraiment bien aimé ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils aiment un ton en
dessous en dessous du panier donc à voir
sinon trois défaites en quatre matches
oui ces quatre matches ok donc olivier
sarre en premier choix
on imagine que je conclus là dessus ce
serait déjà bien qu'ils soient au second
tour olivier qui était pas forcément sur
sur les tablettes des scott alan ouais
les appels que la semaine comme on a dit
je t'ai demandé d'en choisir trois donc
des joueurs ils peuvent être américain
ou pas d'ailleurs ils sont simplement
juste pas français et qui joue en nba et
qui sont pas première année et qui
peuvent être drafté donc sur les années
précédentes on a pas mal d'exemples mais
pour le top 10 seuls de 2020 on peut
citer hobbit opinion way halliburton et
qui rend les 800 l'autriche exactement
donc qui qui va être ton qui râlent et
oui cette année c'est pas du tout le
même profil mais je vais parler de clint
johnson donc le joueur de florida gators
ya pas mal de joueurs des gaiters qui
aurait pu peut-être prétendre à cette
liste parce qu'ils ont aussi deux
sophomore qui a un peu déçu quand la
première année qui reviennent aux côtes
il est au lycée est très mal mais je
parlais de côté johnson qui ont des
dunks et un junior à les refaire sa
troisième année à florida est en fait je
vous rends lui vraiment le un solide
role player
fatigué il a tout pour être vraiment ce
joueur de complément qui va jouer
longtemps et parce qu'en fait il est
qu'elle conduit l'île a déjà qui joue il
joue au poste 4 mais il fait moins de
deux mètres il joue au poste 4 mois
vraiment alors je veux pas les
comparaisons c'est nul car on n'aime pas
mais il pleut il fait il a le même rôle
aux guérites anciens carpiquet de coeur
à à houston
c'est à dire que c'est un joueur qui
défend il peut défendre toutes les touts
les toutes les positions adverses sa
gentille et un jour de fin de chaîne en
attaque donc soit on lui donne la balle
et il tient dans un coin soit on lui
donne la balle et il finit en créateur
un genre qui possédez un super bagage
technique un super en deuil par contre
c'est un des meilleurs défenseurs du
championnat je pense on est défenseur le
plus polyvalent et voilà un joueur qui a
tout joueur d'équipé je pense vraiment
et avec son profil défensif est le genre
de fonction intelligent il peut être un
très bon rôle player et finir le premier
tour parce qu'il est très athlétique ça
c'est les offres saas et déjà on sait
déjà qu'il est très athlétique qu'est ce
que tu vas observé du coup puisque tu
sais qu'il est athlétique qui défend
bien on va qui finit bien auxerre qu est
ce qu on pourrait observer chez lui le
tir et le volume de tir ça serait bien
qu'ils prennent plus de tirs à
proprement et la vie preneur 25% de ses
tirs à trois points pour un role players
will be est souvent le volume est plus
important je viens de tirs à 3 pts à
trois points pris puis c'est pas non
plus un shooter qui perd naturellement
qu il y avait des pourcentages qui était
pas affreux par moments mais sur des
volumes plus petit donc qui vient qui
est un poète des pourcentages solide sur
un volume peu lourd c'est quelque chose
que je quittais johnson floride à ne pas
confondre avec florida state ou parlera
une prochaine fois du scotty barnes
évidemment qu'on n'a pas cité la semaine
dernière je crois c'est un nom à retenir
nico après rocco père cassine je te
propose c'est à blanc espagnol
ces seigneurs moossmann ovarienne
ousmane garuba de 0,3 2002 lui aussi
espagnole il joue au real madrid lui
c'est un cas qui vend un vrai de vrai on
sait déjà jeté des pierres d'un groupe
whatsapp à cause de lui il ya les pro et
les anti
il ya ceux qui voient en lui un drame en
green 2.0 et il y en a d'autres qui voit
un futur boss tout un futur où drafter
donc ousmane pourquoi on se pose toutes
ces questions parce qu'il fait de maître
0,3 et que il évolue quasi uniquement
près du cercle
j'exagère il tire à trois points les
pourcentages sont pas horrible mais sa
gestuelle pose question le pourcentage
aux lancers francs aussi il a dominé les
catégories de jeunes grâce à son corps
sa puissance est maintenant il faut
absolument qu'il développe son tir pour
exister au plus haut niveau
donc lui ce qui est vendeur avec lui
c'est son physique c'est son impact au
rebond c'est sa capacité à défendre au
sol même si pour ceux qui ont regardé
masse contre l'euroligue en euroligue
contre l'asvel
forcément face à moustapha tall sall il
a plus de dix centimètres de moins en
galère et c'est un peu ce que ce que les
gens lui prédisant une biais de l'autre
côté si ils arrivent à développer son
tir extérieur axe deviennent plus fiable
ce qui là en plus c'est sa capacité à
créer par la passe donc l'étiquette de
petit pivot ok sauf que si vous êtes un
petit pivot vous êtes capable de nous
écarter et 2 et de créer par la passe en
plus d'être dangereux par le tir
forcément vous êtes un vrai dire nba
material donc sur la comparaison
certains osent la comparaison que
mathias le sort mathias je croyais un
tout petit peu plus grand beaucoup plus
énergique mais bon ça peut donner des
repères à ceux qui suivent la gémellité
qui connaissent pas ou mal garé au
niveau du gard abdoun garuba du gabarit
de garou bas c'est à peu près ça peut
presser la matière
le sort en dehors size et énergique
ousmane garoua à suivre pareil ça fait
longtemps qu'on le suit et on a dû faire
des podcasts on a fait des podcasts par
le passé
qui parlait de lui notamment après
l'euro et 16 à l'époque et même il ya
plus longtemps bien longtemps que ça
puisqu'il fait d'autres ouais c'est ça
le rouge 18 manu qui est le deuxième
français jouant en acier qui peut être
drafté en 2021
je vais passer sur un joueur plus petit
je vais aller vers jouer à la gare de
gonzaga
ok alors joël aie aie aie on en entend
parler parce qu'il ya comme un gars qui
est très fort il va être sans doute un
peu éclipsé au niveau 2 de la presse par
par hadja laenser avec qui il joue et
qui est potentiel tome 10 dont on a
parlé dans le podcast précédent
parle-nous de joël son profil son
évolution et puis voilà ce qui est
vendeur chez lui en pour les cartes nba
à yayi c'est un loser cas été très
performant l'année dernière c'est un peu
pour ça qu on en parle un peu plus
notamment cette année donc c'est un
un joueur mois que j'appelle hybride qui
peut jouer un peu un sur plusieurs
positions 1 2 ou 3 ans l'ancien pape au
niveau au dessus
donc cette année c'est un il a beaucoup
de responsabilités que comme tu disais
notamment parce que tan rouge trou team
qui qui fait l'effort à l'intérieur ce
succès à l'extérieur qui prend beaucoup
beaucoup de ballons aussi et c'est un
c'est un jour quelques mois je trouve
bon temps dans la tête du du cercle
malgré un premier pas quand même assez
moyen mais il a il arrive à passer créé
son soutien face à des équipes non
lambda encore faut qu'il arrive à cette
époque un peu là dessus est aussi sur le
coup
moi je trouve qu'il progresse pas de
d'année en année donc ça ça m'inquiète
un peu c'est plus à un niveau du tir
c'est plus moi je le vois plus à terme
comme un cac ce catch and shoot heures
car un joueur capable de tirer en sortie
de dribble de secret son son tir lui
même mons à ce status à savoir comment
il va
il va s'améliorer et c'est aussi un
joueur qui est assez intéressant au
rebond mal de sa taille ne clame un peu
moins d'1 95 et je crois que c'est un
truc comme ça
6-6 il s'est alors qu'ils étaient bons
au rebond aussi cette année il ya plus
de sept reprises donc c'est quand même
super intéressant donc j'ai à voir quel
os
s'il va réussir à un peu a ciblé le 1 un
rôle un peu différent de donner les
dernières un peu plus ce que tu n'en
c'est un d'un sac
c'est drôle chim voir cris verse aussi
qui intéressant que moi je vais surtout
de voir voilà s'il va réussir à adopter
ce ce nouveau rôle pour lui un rôle
peut-être plus proche de ce qui pourrait
produire en nba joël hi hi hi à suivre
du côté de gonzaga évidemment gonzaga
ils vont être hyper exposé donc si il
performe dans ce contexte là les gens
seront venus peut-être voir johnson
mais le verrons également et ça peut
être un moyen aussi de faire monter sa
cote évidemment alan on parle de qui
après kate & johnson bornes de james
bond knight à ça ça va faire plaisir à
jb on salue le l'un des patrons des
podcasts transatlantique un ca de uconn
aussi parce que yukon reviendra beast
ouais donc ça va être sympa parce que
aulas l'évaluation ce sera ce sera
vraiment cool de le voir contre les
problèmes de la vie j'ai un autre
c'était l'atlantique tél ou la la
relance et l america naa c est pour nous
comme et c'est que l'abbaye c'est un
niveau au dessus et m'ont vraiment aidé
amoureux de la ville que c'était moi
c'est ça va être cool de warrington et
parce qu'en fait je connaissais pas trop
g on le voyait un peu tourné dans je
voyais tous les instants des articles
dans des podcasts les meilleurs jours du
retour
puis j'ai regardé yukon du aussi
en fin de semaine dernière j'ai regardé
un autre match et j'ai dit et je me suis
dit ouh il faut vraiment l'inclure parce
que donc c'est un c'est un arrière donc
un arrière de deuxième année
un arrière qui dévore en score pendant
est vraiment dans le scoring qui est
vraiment hâte et iq et qui est un cas un
profil assez complète secourir à
plusieurs niveaux proches du cerf à
trois points un peu de mi distance aussi
qui est un un père aimant un bel athlète
très tonique qui monte vite un pied ou
deux pieds qui est tous points contre
attaque de facto et qui voit là quand il
faut essayer ou contre d'autres équipes
que qu'on a qu'on a pu voir a montré de
belles capacités aux tirs donc moi ce
que je vais attendre pour lui je pense
que c'est un genre qui va vraiment être
un pont ce bon bon bon scoreur initiés
je vais attendre à ce qu est-ce qui est
ce qui peut voilà perdus moindre balle
qui fait de passes décisives
parce que c'était quelqu'un sa première
année et voilà est-ce que c'est ça peut
être autre chose qu'un dimensionnelle
qui domine par son physique mais c'est
vrai que ce que ce qu'on voit ce qu on
entraperçoit ça peut vraiment être un
jour qui qui va mettre des points mais
moins de billets donc c'est toujours
intéressant
ouais on en a connu des arrêts hier
surtout qu'ils se révéler un peu sur le
jeu 46è qui faisait deux ou trois
saisons
moi je pense tout de suite à damier nuit
là comme dit ça si tu compares les stats
de tamani l'ardent tant que freshman et
les stats de james goodnight il me
semble que tu tombes pas loin de la
pomme ne tombe pas loin de l'arbre mois
puis il était à 82 % dans ces fraudes et
franchement ça laisse à penser que sont
34% 3 points qui est déjà pas si mal
c'est un jour c'est un jeu quand as tu
prends beaucoup de tireurs sortie ça
peut laisser penser à ce qu'il appelle
progression ça sera étudiée on l'attend
plus propre en tout cas d'un mètre 93
pour donner sa taille qu'il serait monté
à 96 selon ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai
trouvé
ah d'accord il gagne facilement un lynch
noir selon les chaussures les
les prospects que c'est toujours à
prendre avec des pincettes mais
effectivement s'il a grandi c'est bon si
nico un autre prospects européen
je crois que l'on est toujours sur
l'européen moi j'en ai deux africains
européens donc à ce que l'on dit alors
finissons sur l'europe et on ira sur les
prospects après les deux africains
jouent en europe vers évidente oui ok
alors le troisième européen
c'était le plus vieux c'est d'ailleurs
le seul payet en 2002 que je vous
présenter aujourd'hui c'est rock as you
go by this donc un mètre 93 qui joue au
zalgiris kaunas
alors c'est la surprise du chef couvé
par sa majesté sarunas l'an dernier les
années précédentes
il a exposé en début de saison surtout à
la faveur d'un match incroyable à
olympiakos où on a découvert un
redoutable joueur de pick and roll
malin comme un singe tête haute un vrai
bon passeur en mouvement s'est vu son
âge c'est assez rare d'être aussi à
l'aise balle en main parce que pour moi
par exemple c'est un meilleur passeur
que mal et dont usain l'an dernier dans
le dans cette
timing de passoire là c'est vraiment
pour moi c'est sa valeur ajoutée c'est
le jeu sur piqué dans le global man et
sa qualité de passe
il n'y a pas que ça c'est une teigne en
défense un chien une vraie adresse à
trois points il ya 37 % en euroligue à
trois points
donc voilà c'est très solide c'est un
joueur qu'on ne voit là qu'on aime
regarder le point d'interrogation
il situe au niveau physique moi j'ai
envie de dire à ceux qui doutent de son
physique si sir vie dit ça a été drafté
yacoub haïti ce le sera il aurait pu
être un vrai style cette année en
deuxième tour il ya eu une grosse hype
parce que son match à l'ompi à coup sûr
la fin une vague sur la fin est en fête
avec son agent il s'est rendu compte
bon bah on a une grosse hype ok mais si
on continue comme ça toute l'année
prochaine on a un premier tour qui nous
attend jeudi aucun deuxième tour un peu
en mode discret donc du coup ils ont cru
ils ont préféré l'option de se retirer
pour se représenter les projets l'option
recasse au premier tour
une draft où il n'y a pas énormément de
meneur m relative se faire assez rare de
vrais meneurs on aura des initiateurs
mais plutôt de taille ailier donc
pourrait tirer son épingle du jeu avec
un profil un peu différent et pourquoi
pas roccat ce jeu cobayes tizio cobayes
ccvo plein on dit aux cobayes tissant
lilas et manière 9e et bien je m'excuse
je vous prie de m'excuser de la
communauté auditeurs lituanie ils sont
nombreux on les salue
manu c'est ce que devenait en toi c'est
les français du coup mais est ce qu'il
ya un lituanien dans l'équipe du joueur
que tu va présenter non y'en a un bon
côté de gonzague
j'en appelle chez les ch et le troisième
c'est qui alors s'il fonce donc un
joueur cas pas encore joué cette année à
cause du duc ovidie la whey trois
matches ont été annulées donc
normalement le premier match depuis
l'annoncé leur dont deux jours cependant
mercredi du coup c'est ce soir à la date
de sortie du du podcast normalement donc
contre colorado
on va voir si ça sera maintenu ou pas
donc il poussé un petit post 4 5 très
très athlétique donc du petit larousse à
admettre qu'au moins de deux mètres
c'est plus ou moins la même taille que
tajani donc voila mais sauf que lui il y
joue à l'intérieur
défenseurs l'aide de l'année l'année
dernière en as ici avec avec ken ici
donc c'est un monstre physique cros gros
défenseur sur l'homme est aussi
intéressant dans la défense des équipes
donc ça c'est et c'est vraiment là
l'habitude est bon dans mon encontre
aussi pas forcément son arme principale
mais intéressant là dessus et un peu à
l'image de sa rossi l'a montré kg qui
pouvait un peu s'écarter de plus en plus
sur ces 3 et nos classes à un senior il
va faire sa quatrième année il a il a
montré sur les trois années précédant
qui s'écarte un petit peu plus donc ça
va être intéressant aussi à suivre et
notamment de te parler les équipes nba
qu'avec qui l'ont interviewé l'année
dernière parce qu'il l'a il avait mis
son nom pendant pendant la laf la phase
ii pas trop comment on appelle ça très
draft combine il avait mis son nom pour
tester sa cote un peu donc à voir si les
les équipes ont ou vont avoir à nos yeux
euh là dessus pour pourquoi pas cette
année en juin prochain le sélectionner
je pense que c'est un deuxième tour un
peu comme un peu comme paris yahiaoui je
le vois mal aller un peu plus haut un
peu plus haut que que le deuxième tour
pop décisions difficiles on l'avait eu y
font s'ils nous avaient fait le plaisir
de venir dans le podcast l'année
dernière si vous voulez retrouver la
vidéo à l'époque oui déclaré sa
candidature justement la draft mais ce
sont des pré candidature après ils ont
l'occasion de se rétracter a décidé de
se rétracter revenir pour une quatrième
année à tennessee c'est pas évident ce
genre de décisions pour expliquer un
petit peu d'ailleurs il en parle dans
l'interview avec nous il disait ça va
dépendre de ma cote
ils ont ils ont des espèces
d'estimations qui leur reviennent qui
disent 'voilà t'attendre % de chances
drafté premier tour 30% de chances
d'être drafté fin de premier tour 30% de
chances d'être drafté deuxième tour
tonnes pour cent de chances d'être non
drafté
visiblement ce n'était pas satisfaisant
les retours qu'il a eu donc ils
espéraient je pense une fin de premier
et tout cas c'est slim semble ce qu'il
avait dit et du coup ils peuvent hui il
vit sans doute cet objectif
pour finir vite fait manu tennessee
qu'il ya plutôt une bonne équipe sur le
papier cette saison et il va pouvoir
briller aussi exposé ouais ouais ils ont
l'un notamment il ya un joueur qui va ta
à suivre c'est
dryden springer c'est un petit mâle
petit meneur freshman mai
et entre nous ont gardé une base solide
de juniors seniors qui se connaît par
coeur donc ça peut ça peut faire
beaucoup beaucoup de mal an et si si ça
va être une équipe à suivre en tout cas
il fonce donc du côté de man u on
rappelle les français rensing et il
fonce
joël hi hi hi olivier chardon qu'olivier
ça arrive qu'on seront dé facto
candidats puisqu'ils sont seniors je
l'aï 8 fera prendre une décision à la
fin de l'année alan après le junior qui
ont hanté johnson le sophomore james
book night qui est le troisième acteur
classe man que tu as choisie avec des
chances de se faire drafté au premier
tour mag j'ai pris le combo antoine
bérenger rio do so menus j'arrête
pautler geffard les deux très rapidement
auquel tu commences qu'ils se
ressemblent en mentionnant piol johnson
à l'athénée cyan freshman aussi à suis
intéressé à ces on a tous hâte de voir
cette équipe je pense mais dont cariou
de sommes-nous meneur quoi de 3e année
donc du côté de l'illinois et jared
peters aussi de trois moines et je veux
les payer leur raisin peut rassembler
parce que ça vanne je pense les
meilleurs joueurs de deux super bonne
équipe et d'essayer en fait se sont déjà
affrontés en plus les deux la semaine
passée c'est des meneurs initiateurs ont
forcément très athlétique surtout pour
boehner lors d'ailleurs que j'avais
écrit sion se positionner portes l'année
passée en pensant qu'ils allaient
cependant très adroit d'actualité cdh et
jean paul ii lire très très bon oeil
très bon joueur collectif avec un tir un
peu en question du fait d'une mécanique
pas exceptionnel au sein d'un collectif
de baylor extrêmement bien huilé bien
coaché dans l'habituelle période où
sommes-nous lui qui avait des
pourcentages de tiers qui ne permettait
pas d'être amorcée l'an passé parce que
c'était pas assez bon mais la mécanique
et d'autres moments où d'autres tournois
où il a tiré notamment activé chez les
jeunes peuvent laisser penser que tirera
mieux ce qu'il a fait l'année passée et
ce qui sera le meilleur joueur de
l'équipe d'illinois aussi ce qui est
l'une des favorites de la big ten et
et on espère tous constructeurs à march
madness et tout est donc une bonne
équipe de 2006 et cette année
donc il a un petit peu rassemblé parce
que je pense que s'ils font une bonne
saison si loin en mars s'ils montrent
qu'ils peuvent être un mode de combat
que meneur nba tu es troisième corde une
rotation ils peuvent se glisser entre 20
et 30 ans donc je les assemble et ils
ont l'avantagé l'un et l'autre surtout
d'eau sommes-nous je suis en train de
vérifier la taille de jared butler wac
est plus petit mais dosunmu mossoul où
il a passé mon sens c'est intéressant
pour la vieille mais elles ont une
envergure vous conseille le visionnage
de baylor avec plein de garde est
généralement un intérieur qui sait faire
que contre est allé aux serbes c'est
rigolo et ils inouï pour évidemment
koffi cockburn qui est et andre berto
rennais est superflu il est intéressant
et béziers nashville voilà et adam
miller aussi franchement c'est vraiment
une super idée ouais c'est une équipe
sympa à voir
et puis dosunmu ce qui est un des
joueurs assez clutch de l'ancien que si
un match assez serré que vous avez
l'occasion de vous brancher fut comme ça
vous pourrez par la lettre qu antoine
sur twitter ce qui dit qu'il aimait
recueil burton depuis un an et demi
c'est vrai nico on va finir avec nos
deux prospects africains dans l'ordre de
dans lesquels tu les attend à la draft
mais on peut les faire d'une pierre deux
coups on va dire pour finir c'est ouais
c il ya une vraie pièce à m parce que
alors d'un côté vous avez hibou badji 2
m 16
sorte de marsupilami alors paul et pour
les adeptes du porn basket on appelle ça
indique dunker voilà vous avez les
highlights ils sont disposés c1 c'est un
joueur c'est un monstre physique
maintenant la technique elle est limitée
c'est en 10 puis deux ans et ça
progresse pas son registre c'est le près
du cercle transition rôle rebond
offensif sur le post up c'est bof
par contre défensivement bon c'est un
monstre de m 16 qui peut sauter quand on
passe à table sur 1,6 qualités
athlétiques forcément mais dans les
attitudes
moi je trouve que c'est pas toujours
basket et notamment pour ceux qui
suivent de l'afro u18 en ce moment on le
voit c'est pas dingue
il ya des primes de lecture sur je
postais cd cherche toujours à se
retourner son épaule gauche et pas il
n'y a pas de mouvement donc pour
l'instant il joue dans l'équipe 2 du
barça ce qui n'est pas forcément un
handicap on sait il ya eu sa manager et
un coup roach qui ont été été drafté en
étant en faisant partie de l'équipe 2 du
barça
donc c'est pas c'est pas grave puis
surtout voilà tout le monde le connaît
c'est un c'est un des chouchous de pas
mal de scouts américains donc à suivre
je pense que potentiellement ils vous
badji démarre la saison avant khalifa
diop khalifa diop c'est de mettre 11 lui
aussi né en 2002 au sénégal et lui
jouent à gran canaria en europe cup
c'est pas du tout ils boudent hadji ok
c'est plus petit mais voilà c'est un
menhir qui vous chez un menhir mobile
une envergure de 2 mètres 22 quand même
c'est plus au sol que badji mais c'est
aussi plus basket
même s'il a démarré plus tard il ya
quelques moves dos au panier il ya
quelques tirs mais distance donc il
n'existe pas encore vraiment loin du
cirque mais ça arrive c'est un bon
poseurs d'écran il s'est découvert une
passion pour pour le côté rugueux des
écrans et de la bataille dans la
raquette donc c'est cool
moi je vais à 75 qu'il aime bien et
puisque moi ce que j'adore chez lui en
fait c'est que il ne fait pas ce qui ne
sait pas faire
tu vois toujours dans des shows de 6,6
qui sait faire c'est bouché il va faire
la passe et ils sont juste passées et
intéressant donc
donc voilà c'est pas un joueur plein de
feintes plein de move qui va faire se
lever de leur chaise les lé coach serbe
mais
mais il ya beaucoup de choses pour lui
et puis pour avoir bossé sur ces intel
c'est du velours
il fait l'unanimité c'est un bosseur il
est mature et les gentils et j'ai cru
comprendre que c'étaient en train de
devenir le chouchou numéro un de notre
collègue préféré dit espionne donc du
coup je pars je parie sur une montée en
flèche de sa cote si continua à jouer en
europe comme il le fait actuellement et
ben voila envergure comme d'habitude
vous aura prévenu de de l'avenir boule
de cristal pour nico et j'ajoute quand
même que les joueurs grands et épais ont
plus souvent réussi ces dernières années
que le joueur grand et 100 en nba
bah du coup on a fait le tour je crois
je vous avais pas demandé de faire
est-ce que mme agnew alan vous veulent
donner leur chouchou leur pronostic sur
le match
ibou badji khalifa diop est ce que on a
donné la nationalité du gouvenement et
200 sénégal voyais plus joie diop et
plus je préfère diop
ok tu es dans le mou dans le mouv rond
que je mange
ok bon penche vers diop c'est parti là
bas après j'ai eu ce qu'ils veulent je
trouve qu'il fait beaucoup plus joueur
de basket que alan tu as vu toits plats
froids ou 18 mois je regarde watch en
train de regarder et des conseils de
quoi regardé par mon maître nico donc on
échange dans des scellés gymnase
magnifique un coeur c'est magnifique à
regarder les fans de la croix c'est
génial c'est super cameron qui suis un
peu comme il peut bref on fait une badji
badji c'est une idée et job c'est un
joueur de basket pour monde
mais la théorie gbadji elle est sûrement
plus intéressante que la théorie de
cartes mais pour le moment
tu préfères dieu la grâce à ces derniers
mais c'est vrai que le hibou quand il
protègerait à 2034 envers les joueurs
quand même c'est vrai c'est clair
d'ailleurs ni qu est ce que tu avais tu
avais un truc à nous dire sur les
prospects plutôt franssens y est puisque
cette année tu auras une chronique sur
les européens n 6 et donc suivre à sidon
français mais est ce que pour le toile
sur ay ay ay pons sarr tu mettrais une
pièce est sur lequel pour aux hôtes
deuxième tour voire premier sur sarre
hi hi hi par contre il fonce j'adore
adorable de tous mes jeux j'avoue que
j'y crois ok mais pour argumenter de ça
une autre fois et puis on va revenir
évidemment pour d'autres scouting report
plus en détail comme je vous le disais
en début d'émission on va revenir là dès
la semaine prochaine puisque on va vous
faire un podcast par semaine en tout cas
ça va tout le temps sortir le mercredi
parfois il y aura peut-être deux
semaines sans podcast mais voilà vous le
savez désormais votre podcast envergure
il sort le mercredi midi
et puis vous vous pouvez consommer quand
vous voulez dans la semaine pour çà a
essayé de faire des choses assez
intemporel do we pour le dîner pour
goûter pour le dîner au québec c'est ça
en ce moment on vous conseille de
regarder la n6 ya plein de gros match et
on vous conseille aussi si vous ça vous
intéresse puisque il ya des joueurs très
avec beaucoup de potentiel de regarder
comme le fond manuel année nico le le
championnat d'afrique des moins de 18
ans qui a donc lieu en egypte et qui
nous régale par son folklore des
gymnases et ses décors incroyables
exceptionnel d'exceptionnel cérémonie
d'ouverture on va parle pas assez mais
vraiment ça mérite ça méritait plus
d'exposition du côté de l'egypte merci
messieurs on renvoie sur notre site
évidemment pour les scouting report pour
les fiches prospects qui s'accumulent
déjà
avec iphoto envergure stats c'est et
puis et puis on continue aussi à vous
mettre des scouting report de joueurs
dont on n'avait pas fait de rapport pour
la draf 2020 mais qui ont été signés
deux par des équipes nba souvent bien
souvent en tout et quand chaque tu donc
donc voilà on reste est resté branché
les jeunes suivent et nous suivez nous
sur twitter et sur instagram puisqu'on
vous mais également de des infos sur
quotidienne sur instagram voilà gros
bisous à tout le monde et puis à bientôt
très bientôt pour l'épisode 3 ciao